I'm correct with me now and John first
of all why did mr. Carmichael suddenly
make this submission you mean the
statement today well it cuz he's been
found out basically what's happened is
that at the time of the row it's over
broke over the Easter weekend story
appeared in The Daily Telegraph on
Easter Saturday he said ok I'll gask sir
jeremy heywood the cabinet secretary to
have an inquiry that has now concluded
reported today he's been found out and
the it is slightly vague the Cabinet
Office statement because on the one hand
it says that the special adviser you and
Rawdon accurately recorded the
conversation enders this bit this little
bit which Cabinet Office officials are
pointing us to our but look at the bit
where it says it might have been lost in
translation he's been found out he's had
to hold his hands up and admit okay it
was me at the time he wins some
interviews I think he was denying it
that he's going to lose some money out
of this he's going to lose severance pay
of sixteen thousand eight hundred and
seventy-six nearly 17,000 pounds and as
you've heard from Nicola Sturgeon I can
just imagine when it's the first
scottish questions or when it's the
first scottish debate in parlin at those
56 MPs are going to absolutely savage
Alistair Carmichael he may have to make
an apology in Parliament she's saying
consider his position realistically he's
not in a quit his seat she talks about
his majority there she talks about how
he fought the election on a false
pretense because of course of what he
claimed about her it's embarrassing with
hindsight he probably wishes he'd held
his hands up her other time and admitted
okay yes I did leak it he's made matters
worse now and of course there are 56
scottish national party mps only one of
him he's in for a rough ride when the
commons is back in act there is still as
you point out in your report this slight
? Nicola Sturgeon denies it the French
ambassador denies it the man who took
the minutes of the note denies it and
yet Cavanaugh is just saying well that's
what we think was reported to us as
having been said it's Rick abon at
office report is slightly inconclusive
although they do say there's no evidence
of any political motive a
or dirty tricks the Cabinet Office
seemed to have is placing the blame on
this poor young special adviser they
often carry the cam don't they you and
Rawdon seem to be suggesting oh well he
might have slightly misheard what he's
told I got the wrong end of the stick or
whatever but you heard the
consul-general when James Matthews our
Scotland correspondent spoke to him at
the time he was disputing the Daily
Telegraph story as well it should be
said the Telegraph of all is it stood by
their story